we're on problem number seven amit has
two containers let's not look at that
they're they're doing ethnic names now
for the first time someone on the sat
sounds like they might be related to me
anyway ammo has has containers of two
different sizes
the total capacity of of 16 containers
of one size is x gallons
so
okay let me see so let's see container
one so it's container one size and
container two size so 16 containers of
size one so 16 times size 1
is equal to x gallons is equal to x
gallons
and the total capacity of 8 containers
on the other side is also x gallons
so eight
times c2 is also x gallons
and x is greater than zero of course you
can't have
negative
negative gallons
in terms of x what is the capacity in
gallons
of each of the larger containers
of each
let me see with it ameth has containers
of two different sizes the total
capacity of 16 containers of one size is
x gallons right and the total capacity
of eight containers
of the other size is also x gallons and
x is greater than zero
in terms of x what is the capacity
in gallons
of each of the larger containers
okay so all we have to know is about the
larger containers so the oh so the trick
here is which one is the larger
container right that is the trick to
this question
so
this you only need eight of these the
second containers to get x we need 16 of
this container to get to x
so this is a larger container right
and if we want to know the exact size
you divide both sides by 8 you get
container 2 is equal to x over 8 gallons
and you can figure it out container 1 is
equal to
x over 16 gallons
and something divided by 8 is going to
be bigger than something divided by 16.
so this is our answer this is the larger
container x divided by 8 that's choice d
gotta read these problems carefully next
question
whoops
problem eight
rectangle abcd
i'm still getting over the fact that
they had the name mammoth in the sat
anyway rectangle abcd
one day they'll have a salman in there
too and i will be very proud
ab that's my full name i go by sal
because that's what they some people
think that i'm not proud of my ethnicity
but i explained that's what my mother
called me but my full name is salman
it's actually salman khan which is the
name of a
of an indian actor that gets more web
hits than i do
that's life
okay problem eight
rectangle abcd lies in the x y
coordinate plane so that its sides are
not parallel to the axes well all right
let me clear this
i have to focus eight okay it's not
parallel to the axes what is the product
of the slopes of all four sides of a b c
d oh this is fun okay so let me draw it
so it looks like that
like that
roughly i didn't draw perfectly but
these are right angles right
okay so let's say the slope of this line
right here let's say the slope of that
line is m
right
well this line is going to be parallel
to this line so this is also going to
have a slope of m
and this is something you should just
memorize the slope of a perpendicular
line
so slope perpendicular to this is the
negative inverse so the inverse of m is
1 over m it's going to be the negative
inverse so the slope of this line this
line right here is negative 1 over m and
that's something you should just
memorize for life
and of course this one is parallel to
this one it's also perpendicular to
these two so it's also minus 1 over m
so they want to know the product of all
of these so you get
m times minus 1 over m m times minus 1
over m times m times minus 1 over m
m times minus 1 over m this is minus 1
times
minus 1 which equals 1.
and that is choice d
next problem this problem is all based
on did you know that the slope of a
perpendicular line is a negative inverse
red colors all right
problem number nine
an hour long television program includes
20 minutes of commercials what fraction
of the hour-long program was not
commercials so if it had 20 minutes of
commercials 20 minutes commercials it
must have had 40 minutes not commercials
not commercials right
so
minutes over an hour is the fraction
that's not commercial so that's 4 6
which equals 2 3.
that's the answer that's it
problem 10.
if the product of point three
point three and a number is equal to one
point three and a number product of
point three in a number i'll say x is
equal to one it's the product of point
three and x is equal to one
what is a number divide both sides by
point three x is equal to one divided by
point three
and what does that equal to you could
use a i don't know can you use a
calculator on this
but that's essentially i mean you can
multiply the top and the bottom by ten
that is equal to 10
over 3 which is equal to
3 and 1 3 which is equal to 10 well you
could just write 10 over 3 actually
multiply the top and bottom of it or
that's also
3.333 repeating over and over again so
you can do it that way too
next well the product
right did i do that right is equal to 1
right that's right
problem 11
problem
11. let oh i like when they define these
new operations let
okay this is a fun one x
y z
be defined
as
so that means x to the y
x to the y
minus z to the y minus c to the y for
all positive integers x y and z what is
the value of
triangle
3 5.
okay so what's x x is this term
so it's 10
to the y y is this term 10 to the third
minus z
z is this term i'm just pattern matching
so that z is this
and then minus z to the y y is three
that's all it is
so it's ten and third minus five to the
third ten to the third is ten times ten
times ten which is a thousand
minus five times five times five which
is 125
and so that's what that's
875 and we are done
next problem
okay
draw a rectangle let's see the rectangle
looks something like that and then
there's
a line
a line there
and these are points p
q
r
s
t
and u
in the figure above p q s t p q s t
is a rectangle and u r s t is a square u
r s d square so this is a square fair
enough so that means the sides equal
p u p u is equal to five so this is
equal to five
and u t is a positive integer
ut is an integer so that's interesting
we know it's an integer and we know it
can't be negative you can have a
negative
side of a
of a square in our universe if the area
of p q st must be more than 10 more than
ten so area
is greater than ten
and less than thirty area is less than
thirty so we can write it this way area
less than thirty
what is one possible value
of u t
was one possible value of u t well let's
just say that u t is x
right and this is a square so this is x
and this is x as well right
and so what is the area of this
big thing it's going to be this side
which is what 5 plus x
5 plus x
times this side which is x so that's
going to be the area so it's going to be
5 5x
plus x squared
and so that's the area
and it has to be
between these two
spaces right so we could try out some
numbers let's see if x is 1
x is equal to one what's the area it's
five plus one
so then the area is seven no that's not
greater than ten what happens if x is
equal to two
then we have five times if x is two
you have seven times 2 which is 14.
and that satisfies these conditions 14
is greater than 10 and less than 30. so
that's it you have to do x you could
have just said well what if x is you
could have tried one and you should try
you say 5 plus 2 7 times 2 is 14 that
meets my conditions and i am done that's
all you got to do
i'll see in the next video